they'll be facing the right-hander jose
arena he's making his fourth start for
the tigers
numbers a little deceiving pitch pretty
darn good his last time out in
oakland where he threw 21 of 30 first
pitch strikes
he's got a fastball slider
two seamer four seamer and a changeup
and uh a lot of movement down in the
zone so he did a great job getting a
head pound in the zone last time and
thus had a pretty good audience to face
adam frazier
frazier cracks one out toward the gap
and he's gonna be running
a double on the first pitch of the game
and adam frazier with a 13 game on base
streak how about that nice start brian
reynolds in center field
and that one shot into center frazier
read it well he's gonna be waved home
and there will be no throw brian
reynolds with an rbi single the pirates
start with a one-nothing lead yeah
frazier did a good job with that breed
as you said that sound of the bat
probably helped him a little bit too you
could
tell it was not hit well by the
old broken bat sound eric gonzalez with
a big hit yesterday
and that one lined out to center for a
base hit
and reynolds on his way to score
the run is in and so is gonzales who
drives in another and the pirates lead
two to nothing
boy how did gonzalez
not get tagged
he was going to be out by a mile at
second base mitch keller
there needs some work
no better time to get started than right
now
there you go beautifully done and castro
strikes out
see that fastball right out there on the
edge might have been a strike might have
been a ball
but now the hitter
he's got to expand his zone he's got two
strikes on him so here you might get
some chases on some stuff off the plate
so here's jamer candelario with two two
down
there you go look at this that's softly
tapped to third and mitch keller a one
two three inning
pirates take a two nothing lead through
one
two nothing pirates we're in the second
inning
swinging a pop-up down the third base
line candelario long run and he'll make
a nice basket catch with a last-second
swipe that was jose iglesias like
with the swipe up with the glove to make
a nice catch and foul territory one
pitch one out second inning a long way
to go the ball kept slicing away from
him but that willie mays catch
one heck of a play right there baby
another payoff to stallings swung on it
first strikeout of the day for jose
irania
that's that sinking fastball we talk
about his movement in the zone
full count he had to throw a strike
lifted to right center field polanco on
the run is he going to get there he
won't it's going to split the defenders
and goodram has himself a two out double
extra base hitting power from nico
goodram picking up where he left off
last night this combination worked for a
run yesterday akil badu the 1-1
to center field get down
and it gets by reynolds he went diving
don't pay off but dude's gonna cruise
past second hustle to third chip hale
says hold on right there young man nice
job
tigers get to within one badou comes
through again another extra base hit
and the risk for brian reynolds not
rewarded at all
on the bottom of the third
off of keller's glove plenty of time
gets the second out there you go
this has been a
much better outing already for keller
than we've seen oh this is just
i think is best so far
for the castro who struck out back in
the first
goes in with the fastball again
gets over there
that soft earth
one two three inning again for keller
scope drives one to left center
that's a base hit 109 mile an hour of
exit velocity on that he squared it up
well there's niko good room tigers
looking for another two out rally like
they had in the second
oh
96 and keller takes cara goodrum
mitch keller for strong for the pirates
on the ground to short
good room
takes care of business
and pittsburgh is done in the fifth
and he shook a couple of times and then
he shook akil badu striking him out
just a different mitch keller today
and on the inner third he strikes out
another reyes is gone three strikeouts
in a row five today for mitch keller
brings up jacoby jones 2-1 pirates were
in the fifth inning
jones sends one to deep right center
field it's going and it's gone
jacoby jones breaks through
his first homer of the season we're
deadlocked at two impressive piece of
hitting and impressive power two pitches
two outs for urania here in the sixth
got plenty left
five pitches gets him through the sixth
he retires the pirates in order for the
third time here today
this is where pitchers really gotta have
tremendous focus you you realize you're
deep into the game now and the game's
still tied
frazier sends jones tracing and making
the grab
up against the wall
frazier can't believe it
jones patrol center field at comerica
park as well as anybody
and what a chase down
and take away extra base hit opportunity
that was for jacoby jones here's a keel
but do is the one two to him
sends it the opposite way that's deep
it's drifting back back pedaling and
that ball is off the top of the wall
and badou cruises in
with a lead off stand-up double here in
the seventh that'll do
jones to center field that drops let's
watch chip haley's gonna hold but do it
third
a two-hit day for jacoby jones a homer
in the fifth and a single here in the
seventh runners at the corners with only
one out
golfed
out to evans and philip evans saved the
day
peeling that ball from over the wall
against the kill badu two on two out a
2-2 game in the eighth
and on the ground and through
moran comes through
and the pirates have the lead in the
eighth inning
first and third here's eric gonzalez
and that one will get through and
reynolds is in
eric gonzalez with another hit
second rbi today there's your two bob
four to two buckos here the apes
what do you call battle ball baseball
yes i like it
here is now jacoby jones
and richard rodriguez the longest
active scoreless appearance streak
going in baseball 19 in a row without
allowing a run dating back to last
season
he saves game one he saves game three
and the pirates with another series win
on the road